carol baskin just being in the ballroom
is something she never thought would be
her reality
you were not allowed to dance growing up
right
i was taught that it was a spin so it
was something where i tried to resist it
in every way and i think it shows today
so i really have a hard time embracing
it
i'm not gonna hit you yeah i'm gonna hit
me go eight
carol and pasha are rehearsing three
hours a day
but the lion's share of her practice
time actually happens at home
she can clear out her entire living room
she sent me pictures
every 15 minutes i will go through the
routine as many times as i can and then
i put my feet up for 15 minutes and then
i go back and do 15 minutes
and so that's how i spend the rest of my
day the duo is dancing to the lion
king's
circle of life tonight no surprise there
but carol does admit
she's been blindsided by her
ex-husband's family first
they ran an ad about his disappearance
then last week filed a lawsuit against
her
right before the show are you needing a
little fun carol
need you ask you read the news
i actually woke up this morning and as i
was getting ready i was thinking so i
wonder what they could hit me with next
monday
they got to run out of stuff to hit me
with is there a
a tenseness to that i don't think it's a
tenseness because it's been such an
ongoing thing for so long
it's just it's a it's an annoyance more
than anything
you